um just take a second to read it and um
into a bit it says assume the
probability that a child
is female is a half sex is independent
from child to child
just pause for a moment just in that one
sentence right
what's been ticked off here in that list
two options per event identical events
how
what language it didn't say identical
what was the language that told you
independent from child to child so that
means every time you go again
which by the way is not strictly true
sort of um
we're treating that as a whole new event
which is exactly the same as the
previous one
okay giving your answers as fractions in
c plus four
find the probability that in a family of
five children
okay what was the last criteria that i
used
many stages and when did i take it off
just now when i said five children okay
so i mean
it is physically possible to draw out
this tree how many um
options will it have what's the sample
space
that'll be 32 right 32 total options and
i can actually
i can actually miss out some of these
and i will in a second
not all of them but not just a sense of
get a sense of what's going on
okay um now we're asked
find the probability that in a family of
five children and then here are all
these particular situations
okay so let's just start with the easy
ones this is um question one
part a because of the way this
particular question is phrased the first
one
no fancy techniques are required right
what's the probability that every single
one of the children
is a boy now remember i told you you
know this thing is going to be hard to
draw so i'm not going to draw it
but the first option is a very very
simple part of this tree
right if i've got say boy and girl
boy girl etc
how many of these 32 options is
eventually going to be useful to me
only one of them right it's this one
over here that's going to follow
all the boys along here right so
therefore
the probability of five boys
is going to be a half
and i've got to do it five times right
it's the power five yep that gives me
one over
two by the way you'll notice there's a
gap there there's a reason for that i'll
explain it shortly
okay have a look at the next part party
what's it asking
there are two girls and three boys
two girls three boys okay this starts to
become a little bit trickier
right it starts to become a little bit
trickier i'm now going to start to list
some of these options out right maybe
you want to put this off onto the side
with a different color
this option that i've already answered a
question about five boys it looks like
this
um boy
now if i want to do this in a kind of
systematic way this is five boys
right um this next one is about having
three boys that case is a bit trickier
for me
before i do that i'm gonna do four boys
it's actually a lot easier
so this is five boys how would i
what kind of options are there for
having four boys i'm just trying to do
this step by step
well you could have four boys one two
three
four and then you have a girl right
or maybe you have three boys
then you have a girl but you've got to
stay with the four boys right so you
finish off right can you see i'm trying
to list this out in a systematic way
what are the other ways well maybe i
should ask how many other ways are there
there are three more right i could have
to go in the middle
boys either side i could have the girl
second
or i could have the girl first
this is all the ways of having four boys
does that make sense
okay now you can see there's one way of
doing this
there are five ways of doing this when i
keep these all together
right and i say there are five ways in
total do i care about their order
do i care about their order when i say
there are five ways yes
so the way i've listed them the way i've
listed them right
i i have kept i have kept order but when
i say okay
five in total right now i'm like okay
forget where they are
i just know there are five of them and
wherever it is it's no big deal okay
which is why what is the number remember
we're under this right
what's the number that gives me five out
of this
this is actually five c one
for one one girl or if you like i could
have said it's five
c four for four boys because of course
it's symmetrical
right about this one
same thing viewed from both sides okay
which is why by the way i left a gap up
there that gap is for the fact that this
is actually
zero that's how many ways you can get
five boys
there's only one way right okay
so now i'm ready to answer this next
question i'm not going to list it out
because you can already tell me how many
there will be right it won't be one it
won't be five
it'll be ten because that's five to two
if you're
not so familiar with pascal's triangle
yet okay my probability
for what is it three boys two girls
three boys two girls
three boys two guys
is going to be equal too all right how
many ways can i have
three boys and two girls excuse me and
the answer is
five c two or five c three it's the same
number
okay times what
this is still the same fraction i had
before why is that
yeah that's right remember having a look
over here even though i haven't finished
it off right
because they've actually told us there's
actually a special case of binomial
probability
that each of these is the same it's half
half half whichever path you go through
right whichever path you end up like
you've got to go through five of them
and the probably every time
is 102. right so whichever one of these
branches you end up
out of the 32 it'll still be this chance
right it's just that there are more
branches that lead to that option does
that make sense so what's this number
now uh we said this was
10 didn't we so this is 10 over 32
which we can simplify it tiny bit
okay now part c have a look
four boys and one girl okay i'm starting
to get the idea here now right
four boys and one girl in this situation
same as
four girls and one boy all right so the
probability
of what they're asking for four
boys one girl i already have this
right how many ways are that this can
happen five c one
or fast e4 b what's the probability
of getting any of those branches at the
end it's going to be
that okay so this is still going to end
up
like this you see how i'm doing this
right okay
this is a very very simple version okay
i'm now going to give you an example
where
you know just like with volume board
right each of the events
the two options that could happen they
don't have to have the same chance right
sometimes one event is much more likely
than the other okay
so what if for instance i was like
dealing cards
and i was interested in say for instance
all the spades okay all the spades and i
said all right
i'm going to deal a card out i'm just
going to shuffle them and then i'm going
to pull one out at rando
and say what's the chance of getting a
spade right well it's a spade okay there
you go right
didn't even know now what's the chance
of getting a spin on any
particular term it should be a quarter
right because there are four suits it's
13 on 52.
so instead of having something like like
this
right i would say one of them is going
to be a quarter
the chance of getting any other card
will be three quarters
right okay now let's just say for
example
i wanted to deal out a poker hand right
do you remember how many cards running
per game
it's to be five right so one two three
four five like that and what i've got to
do to make sure
that this is going to fit under binomial
probability
right think about this have i ticked off
all of my boxes
two options for event yes yes
all i'm interested is spade or not spade
right um multi-stage events is it
multi-stage do you think is it
is it many stage yeah it's five that's a
lot is it identical
it's not unless i'm pulling out a card
and then putting it back because i need
to reset the deck and make it the same
thing
right does that make sense okay now you
could then work out
if i did it that way okay what would be
the probability
for example of getting a um a flush
a flush means everything the same suit
in spades
what would be the probability
right yeah and there's one way
of doing that yeah what about if i
wanted to get say
three clubs sorry three spades three
spans
okay so you've got each of the spades
right each of the spades but remember
you've got to get
other cards as well right what's the
probability of getting those
other cards it's one minus support it's
the complement
right and how many of those cards do you
have to get two
because remember you've got to follow
all the way along to the end of the
branches
now how many ways are there to do this
think back to my um think back to my
children my boys and girls
right it's going to be 5c
well either 5c 2 or 5 c3 they're the
same number
aren't they okay so you can see here
does someone go ahead and work out what
that number is
45 can i have a percentage give me one
decimal place
all right now then becomes my question
okay
what's the most common number of spades
to get as i do this right
now pause for a second the most common
number
most common number that corresponds to
the biggest percentage
right which is made up of all of these
bits and pieces
these are binomial coefficients right
this is greatest coefficient now i don't
know what the number is but it's not
that hard to work out
is it because you know how to do
greatest coefficients and here are some
numbers that you can choose